So far we have talked about
stack buffer overflows.
Remember we started with the idea of
both overflows and then I quickly
narrowed onto stack buffer overflows or
overflows on the stack.
There are other variations of buffer
overflows and the number of reasons for
those.
We want to talk about
these different types or
variations of buffer overflows before
we actually start talking works and
defenses against these kinds of
attacks that exploit buffer overflow.
So the first variation
we're going to talk about
is what is called return-to-libc.
Libc is the library, C library,
of a program's use library functions.
So, remember when I was talking
about buffer overflow shell code,
modifying return address.
Our assumption was that we're
going to return address,
it's going to be modified to
point to point to some place
where we are able to
place the shell code.
And that could be on the stack itself.
In that case you were transfer control
to the shell code and execute it
off the stack because that's where the
code is told, the shell code is told.
We're going to talk about some
defenses where systems don't
allow you to do that.
So it's not easy to find room for
your shell code on the stack and
get it executed.
So the variations of
where you should return,
you don't have to return to code that
is explicitly write as shell code, but
you can return to
a function in the library.
So the return address is
going to be modified.
The return address that
we had on the stack,
it's going to be modified to point
to a standard library function.
So the assumption here is that
you'll be able to figure out
the address of the library function.
And once you have that,
that's what is going to overwrite.
So when you do the stack buffer overflow
you make sure that library function
address is what gets returned into the
return address field on the stack frame.
So why do we want to do that?
Why do you want to return
to a library function?
Well if you return to the right
kind of library function.
And you're able to setup
the arguments for it.
Or the parameters before
the call happens on the stack.
Then you can execute a library
function with arguments or
parameters of your choice so think about
the library function called system.
The system call,
if you look at it carefully,
you can ask it to execute bin csh or
some csh or something like that.
And as a result of executing this
function call you would launch
a command shell.
That's what our shell
code was doing before.
Now we can get the same result
by executing a library function.
And the reason it will do that for
us is that before we make
the call to it we go to it by
returning from this function where
we were able to overflow the buffer.
We're going to set the stack in such
a way that the arguments actually
are going to be such.
So for example I said the system
calls should execute bin something.
It's going to be such that when hit the
system library function or the library
function's system, it's actually
going to do what you want it do.
In particular give you a shell command.
A command shell.
So when that happens,
you actually then going to execute code
that you didn't have to craft and
place on the stack.
You're just executing
a library function.
And you're manipulating its input
by properly crafting that input
on the stack.
And before you make this
library function call.
And then it's going to do your
bidding if you are that hacker.
So in libc, the thing to remember is
that the return address is modified
to point to a chosen library function
and the setup is input in such a way
that the execution library function,
with that input, allows the attacker
to sort of gain control the same way we
were able to do before with shell code.